hey guys I'm Ryan right hi I'm Veronica
Veronica just saw the video for shrek is
love shrek is life how was it Veronica I
just I just I'm just hurting right now
it's pretty [ __ ] disturbing isn't it
it is so unbelievably disturbing
now I haven't told Veronica but we're
gonna watch next but it's shrek is love
shrek is life
far2 the real one right it's not like a
parody ah it's the sequel to what you
just saw really yeah yeah are you
kidding no not you to put me through the
night oh wait I gotta go through it too
I think it's really disturbing but
everyone should watch it I gotta check
it out ready to change your life around
no I'm not - two minutes of Awesomeness
I can do it
[Music]
it's the last day of school that I'm in
my last class I'm talking to my
supercool teacher I think him for a
Shrek tastic year he says it was
charming to be with you no it can't be I
turned towards him it's just as I
suspected
it was Prince Charming this whole time I
launched after him trying to Lodge
onions in his pretty boy ricktum but it
was no use
as I uncover his anus fairy godmother
emerges and puts a layer restriction
spell on me it's all ogre now just as I
thought my last layer was being stripped
from my soul Shrek crashes through the
ceiling yes without a moment's
hesitation
Shrek grabs charming by the dick rips it
often strangles him with it
fairy godmother tried to fly away but
Shrek pulled out his onion Zuka fairy
godmother burns to ashes
Shrek restores my layers and gives me an
onion I go home with a soreness from his
mess of ogre sized chef shrek is love
shrek is life
[Music]
[Music]
I was very moving
that wasn't as deserving it actually
feels like a step back compared you but
who the first one was I have no words I
just have no words I like its
willingness to commit to something so
Unruh dick you lessly like only an
animation like that could get away with
like the kind of jokes that are cone for
here so that was real people no one
won't find it funny that is just crazy
not yeah it's just ridiculous it's so
over the top seriousness of it is
wanting and taunting like disturbing and
hilarious at the same time so weird yeah
so weird dude yeah it's a unique feeling
its unique feeling sort of like the
unique feelings I have for you Veronica
but if we're not joking well yeah thank
you guys for letting me know part two is
out well worth the time if you're new to
the channel you can subscribe right here
and veronica has her own channel she
does like vlogs it's just a lot of cool
music that'll really move your soul this
rainbow the other dimension butterflies
and you could see her shrek is love
shrek is life reaction on her channel
her yeah it's worth it but worth it yeah
that's pretty insane who the [ __ ] made
that video who is who is putting this
out there this person it was [ __ ]
nuts I heard and sync produced it in
sync yeah they got back together then
became like a production company and
they produced it is this where you try
to fool me no this is like this seems
like it was something that would run in
Justin Timberlake's mind after working
on Shrek 3 this sounds like something
that would run on in your mind friend no
these are facts I read it on Wikipedia
what really oh
I want to get some shoutouts here got
out their name awesome sauce your sauce
is awesome my friend he wants a shout
out so yeah Oh sauce that's not bad that
sounds pretty good could be a cool
commercial what kind of sauce are you
ranch Italian dressing barbecue honey
mustard ketchup relish that sauce that's
not a sauce I [ __ ] that one up [ __ ]
Indian how it hurts when you play along
you know you're not used to it no it
really hurts getting practice I would
not say this is awesome sauce get it
no way oh I know guys guys guys wait a
minute wait a minute wait a minute
awesome sauce is what I call my semen
seriously sorry I had to go in there
that was an excellent idea you know I've
had some I had a commenter the other day
say that I make a lot of unnecessary
sexual jokes and and um this guy my
penis could not disagree more with you
oh he's never he's never
I think it's always perfect timing sorry
Anderson hello how he starts us off I
enjoy your humor your videos always make
me laugh I especially enjoy with maria's
on the show ha
you're not Murray that's what you know
Murray's been getting a lot of comments
lately like me people have been no
definitely I just keep forgetting save
it a shout-out will be righteous ah
righteous like the right tier the Ryan
the right that's a pretty clever one I
haven't heard that one you know it's not
I sometimes I call myself righteous
right righteous Ryan oh that's right and
I was some virtuous Veronica exactly I
have only been introducing yourselves
like that oh yeah there because looks
like it's like our thing cuz we're not
stars of a CW cartoon as super sure I'm
sorry that was really mean I was just
trying to like connect
yeah I am so sorry come here come here
come it's ok puppy it's okay
everything's gonna be all right okay
shrek is love shrek is here anyway Terry
I'm glad our videos make you laugh man
and just did a little bit just for you
hold on I [ __ ] up here and just did a
little bit just for you and I love you
mr. Anderson
mr. Anderson mr. Anderson
remember the matrix mm-hmm was that what
you're doing or were you just doing
something does it sounded pretty good
no I just do impressions of people doing
impression okay all right
hello I'm Christopher Walken hello I'm
Christopher Walken that's not bad all
right here we go hello I'm Oh
Pacino that's right Kermit the Frog my
vocal cords are teeth mmm
I know trust me I know because I had
some awesomesauce go down to Boca cook
no I didn't went a little too far yeah
that did not happen
can I slap you sure weird that I just
got a boner from that
iron wolf you guys deserve a million
subs don't want a shout-out well you
shouldn't have said you don't want to
shout out because now you're getting one
my friend because you were a wolf made
of iron steel metal that's a really dope
little picture thumbnail he got there
yeah he was a wolf that was actually
shot but scientists if I'm correct
scientists actually took the wolf's body
and then turned him into a type of
cyborg wolf and then he became iron wolf
but at first the agency which ran the
whole business didn't want you know him
to be a hero they just wanted him to to
work and then iron wolf eventually
discovered their the crime look your
story [ __ ] sucks
okay what your story [ __ ] sucks well
you would hate the movie Robocop then